qu'est-ce que vous avez privilégié ici
de la phase de préparation parfaite
préparation à travailler sur un petit
peu quand on est arrivés bancaire et il
a fait du footing notre vire toujours un
petit peu en endurance trail est en
résistance pour finir aujourd'hui par
travailler de du fractionné en vitesse
vitesse beaucoup de vitesse ce qui
revient dieu que il est fin prêt pau
vendredi soir oui c'était c'était notre
programme et on finissait s'est très
bien terminée voilà les laisser en
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui avec maintenant
il faut le relais le laisser se
recharger ses batteries
et ça va exploser vendredi l'entraîneur
a préparé son poulain pour la rencontre
de vendredi que savez-vous de
l'adversaire btan c'est ce que michel il
y en a pas beaucoup beaucoup de
deux vidéos je pense que avec les
résultats qu'il a fort à faire attention
dans les premiers rounds
il faut faire attention mais après le
match va basculer partir de 4e 5e je
pense michel avec le la préparation
physique qu'il a il va se mettre à
accélérer et le papa c'est donc en
principe il devait la pause sa position
pour faire toujours pas ce qu'est la
boxe et sur un coup on peut tout mais je
pense que c'est comme ça que ça va ça va
se passer à 11 ans et son plus beau
combat en dehors du championnat du monde
remettre son titre en jeu le plus beau
plus beau c'est le titre que qu'il a
récupéré que l'on récupère ensemble
maintenant il ya quelque chose qui est
bien à lui donc il s'est préparé pour et
veut garder ce titre donc est il encore
en meilleur que l'était l'année dernière
pour aller récupérer le titre